[Music]
to be clear she's at her date's place
and he's like i'll be back and it's been
45 minutes since he went to the room and
didn't come back
so she got stood up
at his place
her name is hannah robinson
uh yeah i know let me talk to you for a
second i know let me talk to you for a
second
um
why are you still there
well she writes in the caption i'll wait
for 30 more minutes and i'll leave i
don't know where he went no no 45
minutes that's a big ass dookie that
that's whoa
okay i'm home now and you're correct so
he's waiting for you to follow him
so this man went into the room and
waited for her to follow him
for 45 minutes oh that's supposedly and
and then she's saying yeah that's
correct so let's find out what happened
oh wow
yeah my man was probably in there
[ __ ] bathrobes pedals just standing
like this i think so i think that's what
they're trying to see okay i'm home now
and you're correct i say 10 minutes
after i posted that i went to his room
and i was like what are you doing
because we're supposed to go out
and he was just laying on his head naked
like waiting
[Laughter]
imagine he's naked on the bed and he's
like
any minute now
any minute now she's going to pop out
the door because i suck my dick any
minute now
and then somewhere out of nowhere just
from one of the events you just hear on
the next episode of dragon ball z
find out
same way goku been powering up
anytime you you know you you take you
you organize a date with a dude right
he's like yeah yeah okay okay but let's
go by my place i need to get changed and
get ready
just know
don't mean you guys are always going to
go out or that's what he's expecting or
hoping sometimes dudes will be like hey
come by my place i'm going to get
dressed and we can go just so they can
see if they can skip the date smash
right away
and that's what happened to her that's
stupid though what's stupid i'm just
saying what's stupid say something say
what i'm gonna get up and be like
it's gonna be like yeah so blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
just go to your room and wait for her
that's funny to me i'm sorry i know but
you know people do that all the time
like very rarely when people say like
come back to my place it's like trying
to grab some coffee my man or do you
wanna yeah coffee me can i can i yeah
you know look everything a lot of folks
do things a little bit like innuendowy
yo that's what i'm saying like
autistic [ __ ]
are right
the people that are in spectrum i'm
talking about the asperger people
they're right
the way they act with some people is
right the thing if it's not clear it's
not it's not a thing yeah or sometimes
you're gonna think the person is rude
mad rube or abrupt like this guy right
here he's not autistic he's not
diagnosed but sometimes he has some
autistic tendencies and i before i was
like what the [ __ ] are you doing but
then i realized [ __ ] you're
right let me tell you what happened we
had a show at a bar okay we were doing
we were hosting this comedy show and
then people would come and we were
hosting the show and then we left and
after that people will come and talk to
us because you know they appreciate what
we do
this [ __ ] with people like
we're talking like there's
me
another woman and this dude and she like
we're just talking about some [ __ ] this
lady comes in start talking to us and
everything and stuff and last one minute
two minutes three minutes and then she
said something to abba and he said
i don't know
and she kept on talking and nobody went
like this
how do we do that and i was like what
the [ __ ] is this but you know what you
might think it's rude but
he did
he was no longer interested in the
conversation he went about his business
i thought i got other places to go
at first i thought this [ __ ] was matt
rude
don't be surprised if i start doing that
[ __ ] now
that's it is actually genius i have
another one of my my one of my friends
uh daughter she's on the spectrum too
and i don't i haven't seen her daughter
uh i don't see her daughter all the time
i see my mom obviously because i don't
hang out with a kid you know i mean
that's [ __ ] weird anyways so i was
chilling with her mother and the kid
popped up and we say hi then
a year and a half goes by and i see the
kid again and i was i was in front of my
my parents place and the mom rose by
just to say hi and i was like oh [ __ ]
that's you i was like hey what's up how
you doing and i go down the window and
i'll be like hey what's up how you doing
and the kid went like this
i don't know who you are and she turned
like this and i was like yes i
understand she's autistic the mom felt
bad but i was like
she is right
the kid is right
i don't know you
i don't i don't know you i don't want to
talk to you you don't really care no how
i feel and after that the daughter felt
bad because she did remember me after
that but in the first thought i was like
that's not rude you guys are right
you guys are right everything being
clear like that and being abrupt
you're right
and this guy probably autistic and went
in the room you know what to expect
let's go let's not pretend
let's just go
gotta see the signs ace of base ah
so
in the finale of this whole saga yeah
what happened then after she found the
date naked and he was hoping to
seemingly roll around in the sheets
before going out
there was going to be no going up
when asked whether or not her dates
trick worked robinson replied yes but no
but yes kinda
what
they [ __ ] okay i'm back home after an
hour you live five minutes away from the
dude come on come on now you [ __ ] it
worked so apparently they went all the
way he came she didn't he then fell
asleep
[Applause]
what did you expect the guy really
hey
okay if y'all just going there to [ __ ]
them this is all fantastic it's all
great if y'all actually try to seriously
date these dudes if we do treating you
like this he don't see you better than
the scum on the [ __ ] bottom of his
foot okay usually something you can
[ __ ] chuck i'm just keeping it
straight okay a hundred that move right
there says
i'm just trying to smell it i'm just
trying and the fact that exactly what i
thought would happen ended up happening
which is they smashed and they didn't
even end up going out which is like of
course not the man didn't have the
courtesy to even try to woo you into bed
properly so of course he's just gonna
smash and then fall asleep because like
he's already deemed you as like
i barely have to try
i don't really even have to go out with
you i just got to give you the pretense
that we might and you'll still [ __ ] me
if we don't you're probably not that's
crazy yeah that's probably that's
probably you're probably known in his
repertoire as 55-minute girl
that's a girl that took her 55 minutes
to come in the room okay
i'm
because it looks like that's what he
does
you know someone said this recently and
i said it was such cat he said like uh i
feel like most guys you know like the
woman that they [ __ ] are the women that
they date i don't like no no listen
dudes don't have plenty women that they
would sleep with that they would never
want to take seriously and
and and that these women are well below
whatever standards they may have in
terms of looks or personalities 100 yeah
wonder why because sometimes guys just
get horny sometimes guys just looking
for a hole to film and guess what
girls will go through [ __ ] just
because they need a hug sure i don't
disagree same same thing same thing i
don't disagree i don't disagree here's
the difference
go ahead go ahead the difference is guys
are happy to be on the receiving end of
that portion women are rarely happy to
be the [ __ ] skin off the bottom of
your feet absolutely okay and i know
what i'm saying sounds harsh but i'm
just letting you know what it's really
like in the head okay so if you go in
don't i don't want to hear you crying
after like i thought he would already
like them okay
i don't know you you but to me
you don't even have the courtesy clearly
you don't respond if a girl says you're
not the one the guy's gonna be like i'm
not the one
yeah
i think he's just gonna bro
they're gonna try to [ __ ]
you're taking off your shirt it's hot
let me tell you sometimes they just take
off the bottom
what the [ __ ] dude well you just took
off your shirt why can't i take off my
bottom paws that's not good
if i'm lying
let the ladies know in the comments if
i'm lying about what i said yeah in
regards to how the guy feels about the
woman those circumstances let the women
know all right leave your comments i
don't think you're lying i think it'd be
like that really it'd really be like